Traduttore: David Mammano
Revisore: Michele Gianella
Di che cosa parliamo,
quando parliamo di utopia?
Cosa vi viene in mente,
se vi chiedo di pensare a un’utopia?
È molto probabile che stiate pensando
a qualcosa di assimilabile
al concetto di desiderio, no?
Un desiderio particolare,
quasi onirico, inconscio.
Il desiderio di raggiungere qualcosa che
sapete darvi un certo grado di felicità,
ma sapete anche che è irrealizzabile.
Siete in crisi con la fidanzata
o con il fidanzato,
cercate di pensare a un nuovo compagno
o a una nuova compagna: un'utopia.
O siete lì che mangiate un panino
tra una riunione e l'altra,
durante una giornata di lavoro,
l'utopia è essere magari a bordo piscina
con un piatto davanti
del vostro cibo preferito.
Oppure l’utopia delle utopie:
magari realizzarsi personalmente
attraverso un nuovo lavoro,
o sostituirsi magari al capo
per prendersi qualche rivincita.
Poi però si aprono gli occhi
e la realtà l'abbiamo davanti:
non siamo il capo;
stiamo mangiando un panino;
e la giornata sta scorrendo
davanti ai nostri occhi.
Queste sono utopie, si dice,
soggettive, personali.
Io ciò di cui voglio parlarvi oggi
non sono le utopie soggettive,
perché non ho la bacchetta magica
per esaudirle tutte,
ma le utopie pubbliche,
le utopie che fanno di noi una società,
fanno dell'insieme di tutti noi
dei cives, dei cittadini;
e sono molto distanti da questa concezione
di desiderio irrealizzabile
che vi ho raccontato nella prima parte.
Perché in realtà,
quando parliamo di politica,
di storia delle idee,
di storia del pensiero politico,
parliamo di utopie laddove vediamo
una strada per cambiare la nostra società.
Vediamo una strada irta, difficile,
vediamo delle cose che non ci piacciono
nella società che stiamo vivendo,
ma vogliamo costruire
un percorso di cambiamento:
costruire un'utopia.
Questo è l'edificio della nuova
Fondazione Giangiacomo Feltrinelli,
in viale Pasubio a Milano,
inaugurato lo scorso dicembre.
Giangiacomo Feltrinelli,
famoso editore e libraio europeo,
prima di essere
un famoso editore e libraio
è stato un grande collezionista
di fonti d'archivio e di libri,
tutti dedicati a fotografare
le trasformazioni sociali dal ‘500 a oggi.
Qui noi oggi abbiamo un milione e mezzo
di carte d'archivio e 250.000 volumi.
Per parlare dell'utopia pubblica,
dell'utopia e del percorso
di trasformazione civile
io vi ho portato un piccolo libricino:
questo piccolo libricino
è l'edizione del 1643
della “Città del Sole”
di Tommaso Campanella,
ed è uno dei pilastri attorno ai quali
noi abbiamo costruito questo edificio
e il progetto di questa
“casa europea delle scienze sociali”
o, come ci piace chiamarlo,
“luogo dell'utopia possibile”.
Questo testo è stato scritto
da Tommaso Campanella nel 1603.
Tommaso Campanella voleva l'autonomia
della Calabria dal Regno Spagnolo,
gli spagnoli non erano molto d'accordo
e lo misero in galera.
Lì lui scrisse tutte le sue opere
più importanti di filosofo politico,
ricordato, studiato
e collezionato in tutto il mondo,
ma naturalmente gli spagnoli
non erano mica tanto contenti
di diffondere le sue idee
e i suoi scritti.
Questo è un piccolo libricino
in formato super tascabile
prodotto da amici di Tommaso Campanella
che volevano a tutti i costi,
nonostante il divieto
da parte degli spagnoli,
diffondere il suo pensiero utopico.
È importante sia per il contenuto
che per la forma:
questo è il frontespizio
e questa la prima pagina.
Vedete: “Civitas Solis”.
In latino è scritta
anche quest'altra prima edizione,
che è contenuta nei nostri archivi,
del “De Utopia” di Tommaso Moro, 1518.
Qui l'isola dell’Utopia
e qui l'alfabeto utopico.
Vi faccio vedere un'ultima cosa:
questa è la bandiera originale
della Comune di Parigi.
Sono due esempi: Tommaso Campanella;
Tommaso Moro, la Comune di Parigi;
esempi di utopie che sono state ideate
o che sono state praticate,
ma potrei andare avanti:
Montesquieu; Rousseau; Machiavelli;
le resistenze europee; le rivoluzioni;
le controrivoluzioni;
la lotta per l'affermazione dei diritti;
egualità; diritti dei neri;
diritti degli omosessuali.
Le utopie le stiamo vivendo ancora oggi:
lo “ius soli” è in dibattito
al Senato, è un'utopia,
ma come lo era la legge
sulle unioni civili l'anno scorso
o ancora il voto per le donne.
Se andiamo indietro,
la società è stata piena di utopie.
Perché ve ne parlo con tanta enfasi?
Non solo perché quel progetto
è dedicato a rinfocolare
la volontà, da parte dei cittadini,
di credere in una società
diversa e migliore
e quella di anche dare
un segnale ai politici
e a chi ci vuole rappresentare
di infondere fiducia
nei confronti dei cittadini
verso una società migliore.
Ve ne parlo proprio perché la qualità
della politica che abbiamo attorno
ha fatto, forse,
un po' di passi indietro
rispetto alla centralità delle idee,
alla centralità di un progetto,
appunto, un progetto
che può essere assimilabile
a quello che definiamo “utopia possibile”,
ma che invece oggi si perde in tecnicismi,
non ha la qualità di quelli
che erano i progetti del ‘900
e non sono aggiornati
ai linguaggi del 2017 o del 2030.
E quindi cosa bisogna fare?
Bisogna riportare al centro
del nostro dibattito
l'esigenza di fondare
la politica sulle idee;
Non solo: sulla costruzione
di un progetto sociale,
sull’individuazione di priorità,
con le quali nutrire
questo progetto sociale,
e le soluzioni che devono essere
protagoniste dei progetti politici
dei quali condividere,
ai quali attribuire il nostro voto.
In Italia questo lo stiamo facendo poco
e in giro per il mondo, in realtà,
ci sono dei personaggi
che lo stanno facendo moltissimo,
anche con un certo successo.
Bernie Sanders è stato protagonista delle
scorse elezioni presidenziali americane,
delle primarie del Partito Democratico,
facendo una politica che è stata
particolarmente innovativa.
Oltre Partito Democratico
e Partito Repubblicano,
Sanders è andato al cuore
dei problemi degli americani,
in particolare sostituendo l’”Obamacare”
e andando a proporre delle soluzioni
in tema sanitario, in tema di sicurezza,
in tema di education...
Milioni, decine di milioni di voti,
e chissà come sarebbe stata la storia
se lui avesse vinto le primarie
e avesse fronteggiato Donald Trump.
In Europa ci sono degli esempi
che di recente hanno
caratterizzato la scena politica
e, di fatto, hanno riportato
la forza del programma
al centro dei programmi politici:
Jean-Luc Mélenchon addirittura
ha creato un nuovo partito:
la "France insoumise”,
la Francia Ribelle,
chiedendo il voto ai francesi
sulla base di un programma in 100 punti.
Il programma l'ha chiamato
“Il futuro in comune”
- “The future to share”;
un futuro in comune fatto di 100 punti,
incentrato sul lavoro 4.0,
sulla difesa dei beni comuni,
un prodotto “di sinistra”
si direbbe nel ‘900,
ma lui non lo dice,
dice [invece]:
“È un prodotto nell'interesse
dei cittadini francesi”.
Non ha vinto la diatriba
con Emmanuel Macron,
ma è arrivato quasi al 20%.
Macron è un altro che, affermatosi
Presidente della Repubblica Francese,
ha fondato la sua politica
sul ritorno delle idee,
ma soprattutto l'idea delle idee,
o meglio l’utopia delle utopie,
cioè l'Europa.
Un grande, una grande affermazione,
un grande disegno politico,
cioè riportare al centro
della geopolitica internazionale l'Europa,
chiaramente, nella sua visione,
un pochino più franco-centrica
rispetto a quella germano-centrica
che stiamo vivendo oggi.
Qui abbiamo una donna: Ada Colau.
Sapete, lei è sindaco di Barcellona,
ha imposto un'altra delle caratteristiche
che dovrebbero governare i soggetti
che si dedicano alla politica,
e cioè la mediazione.
Ada Colau è di Podemos;
è riuscita là dove molti esponenti politici
spagnoli non sono riusciti:
cioè a trovare un punto di equilibrio
tra i partiti tradizionali,
Podemos e gli Indignados.
E oggi, sindaco di Barcellona,
ha dei livelli di popolarità
mai raggiunti.
In Italia ci sono tantissime
situazioni del genere,
ve ne cito una: Domenico Lucano.
Domenico Lucano è il sindaco di Riace,
un piccolo paese calabro
- torniamo da Tommaso Campanella.
Il paese è Riace,
negli anni ‘90 era un piccolo borgo,
di quelli che ci ha raccontato
Marco Magnifico, con più di 4.000 abitanti
Si è spopolato:
molti sono andati in Australia,
molti sono andati negli Stati Uniti,
in cerca di fortuna,
a causa della crisi economica.
Riace era diventato un borgo
di 1.000 abitanti.
A un certo punto Lucano riceve
la telefonata del Ministero degli Interni,
che gli dice, abbiamo
una nave con 300 migranti,
vorremmo attraccare in Calabria
e consegnarti queste persone.
Lui, invece di dire No, dice Sì,
coinvolge i suoi concittadini,
riempie le case chiuse,
- perché appunto gli occupanti
erano emigrati -
e fa una politica
d’integrazione straordinaria.
nota in tutto il mondo,
poco nota in Italia,
che ha comportato.. cosa?
Non solo un progetto sociale innovativo,
ma anche un nuovo
modello economico per la città
e una grande ripresa turistica.
Da Domenico a Riace a Tommaso Campanella,
a Bernie Sanders, a Jean-Luc Mélenchon
sono tutte occasioni
in cui la politica,
le idee, il coraggio,
il cuore e la passione
sono tornate a essere protagoniste
di un disegno che vuole riportare noi
in un futuro di trasformazione sociale,
cioè di conquista
dei diritti che non abbiamo,
di rivalorizzazione dei diritti
che abbiamo conquistato,
di futuro possibile.
Di fatto, tutti in qualche modo
hanno percorso una strada,
una strada nuova,
come ci insegna Gianni Rodari:
il protagonista della sua fiaba
ha tre scelte davanti a sé:
due strade sono già state percorse;
una invece, nessuno ha avuto
il coraggio di percorrerla.
Lui, Testadura lo chiamano,
decide di percorrere la strada
che nessuno aveva percorso mai.
È anche un po' buia quella strada,
perché va in mezzo al bosco,
e non si sa dove porta
e non si vede nemmeno una luce al di là.
I suoi amici lo dissuadono
dal percorrere quella strada,
invece lui dice:
“No, io ci provo: nessuno ha avuto
questo coraggio, chissà dove porta!”.
Allora, lui comincia
a intraprendere quella strada,
arriva nel bosco, il bosco gli si apre:
è un bosco odoroso, meraviglioso;
ma soprattutto vede
una luce al di là del bosco
e viene accolto in una casa
enorme, bellissima,
con una principessa che lo fa entrare
e gli regala pietre preziose,
diamanti, gemme.
Lui riempie un carretto
con queste pietre preziose
e ritorna nel suo paese.
Gli amici gli dicono, ma dove
hai preso tutte queste pietre?
Ho percorso la strada
che voi non volevate percorrere.
Incominciano a percorrerla anche loro,
perché vogliono anche loro le gemme.
Ritornano e dicono,
ma tu sei un mentitore!
Lì non c'è più quella casa
e quelle gemme.
E Gianni Rodari ci dice:
“Certi tesori esistono solo
per chi batte per primo una strada nuova.”
Una strada nuova significa
un futuro nuovo per noi cittadini:
un'utopia possibile
da costruire tutti assieme,
per tornare a crederci.
Grazie.
(Applausi)